all right I welcome to in the video um
this is something different again I'll
do a video on a short one with that bot
30 minutes um hyrum on czesc you playing
um I was own tournament it was an open
tournament with very low entry fee but
it's got some nice prizes here and
actually wonders yesterday so I have
some sleight hopes that maybe I can do
something here another reason I'm and
actually the main reason I'm doing the
video as some because some there's a
charity event on on chest cube here and
this is scheduled for februari the 17th
I'll put the details also in the
description and the event is that a
player here on chess cube called goose
02 02 um you see his cafe here if you
want to read the name don't understand
my pronunciation he'll be doing a
charity on bullets there and he will
play 1000 consecutive bullet games to
raise money for breast cancer research
so its own yeah a good thing I think and
if you play on Jess cube or you are
interested then then join chest Cupid's
for free and lock on there on the
seventeenth it will start them I'm 6
p.m. eastern standard time so this would
be if you here watching listening from
Europe this would be a yeah actually
yeah we're six hours at right yeah this
would be midnight midnight on Friday is
the 17th so from 17th to the 18th on
Europe so saturday morning he will also
play so if you like to just show up and
play some Bulleit games against him or
even better show up in
rumah do some donations whatever and
think it's a good cause and and what it
is always fun so let's combine some
serious useful stuff with funding
sources tournament starting so let's
let's have some games now I'd set the
bullet tournament so I don't expect too
much in terms of quality speed counts
trying to go for quick attack here
certainly not necessarily correct but
try to get something quick going here
yeah like a certainty good here Queen a
three would have been a problem already
this didn't really work out I'm just
much much worse here and most likely
some sacrifices already work down on the
clock to okay try to to get some
counter-attack going if I made that mate
not much I can do going for Ricky 7 or
27 maybe queen age seven ya know that
some counter play
so I didn't find a mate here okay let's
take the night oh man he's threatening a
perpetual let's cover Queenie one okay
one on time this was not the best and
most convincing start I always needed a
couple of games to two get played into
this to this time limit I'm not a great
bullet player by heart but well I can do
decently if I'm in good tunes and
somewhat decent shape yeah okay
this looks nice Queen h.323 scrap all
the pawns that can get try to meet here
on g2 I have to yep f2 for the quick win
yeah mostly play you for in this summer
to to to get in win squeaker sometimes
it's working but I'm not quite sure
maybe I should play my usual stuff
okay i'm just a pawn up into a
comfortable position okay this just
loses a move yeah I won't take this it's
just unnecessary in a bullet game he's
got nowhere to Castle anyway
yeah this is a piece i'll take that
well maybe this is dangerous oh no it
doesn't have you don't have doesn't have
Queen age 7 i'm covering this and this
is dangerous a bit ok try for
counterplay we completely irritated me
with this crap i lose on time this was
bad really bad
what is also quite slow don't think he's
pre moving maybe ask some some some
slight chance as always got a huge lag
even one on time because he was terribly
slow at the end terrible game of course
oops this wasn't intended ok and this is
a tricky one this hitch this trick is
really really old but it's working
wasn't intended though I didn't mean to
play five
yeah this is comfortable maybe this way
to get something going on the kingside
always give them your pawn or I could
have taken the bishop I'm not not quite
not quite in good shape here it's it's
still very good for me of course but
should have taken the bishop okay let's
go win this end game
I should be winning despite the double
corns i played this tattoo quickly if I
have to all this reserve moves here so
okay well on time most likely oh well
this was really bad I want the title
tournament completely unnecessary yeah
one on time this is one of the most less
deserved second places okay this is not
really great but it's it's nice and
aggressive and bullet oh hi
well at least I've got some proper
development all this looks strange
threatening threatening a quick made I
don't see move d 5 is hanging so yeah
I'd long castle next or maybe I can take
on g4 even not sure better castle
this looks fine again threatening III
and g2 and he sees it was even slower
than me I'd have been slow okay I'll
take this yeah this is a deadly pin oops
not on route III got to be careful with
the primos yeah moving in the lead with
six out of six but play has been
terrible yesterday I managed 23 out of
23 years so I also played much more
games whoa I'm so slow okay I got a time
energy at the beginning so yeah pretty
standard stone wall formation
I go for 90 fe5 and f3 next try to open
up the center maybe rookie one also this
thing has doesn't have a square the
night is trapped on the form you can
take care but I can check with the pawn
this is playable due to the f7 Bishop of
72 singing at the end he cannot take
white tape with the problem with the
pawn and this will open up the diagonal
also if you kept just now yeah now Queen
g7 threatened Oh
somewhere i missed i'm sure i miss the
meteor or something oops okay this was
at least a clean win yeah Mon second
place but I'm playing slow and not
terribly good yeah this looks like a
fine position to try to run to run him
over I could have gone from gone for
discovery already here maybe try on f2
oops this was quick yeah those always
help also some people just resigning
without clay would be nice it doesn't
happen so often
mmm do I have some trick here okay
better I'm so slow I'm down on 34 it's
unbelievable position is fine but time
management is just ridiculous
yeah this I was hoping for this should
be fine again let's keep it simple with
the rook endgame this should be winning
with that with this strong poem on the
farm yeah this thing is just going
through ok 9 of 9 they are very soft no
idea about this stuff maybe try to get
some some quick play here hope it
irritates in a bit
most likely a plate 6 now no it didn't
but now I should yeah but this is just a
piece I should have some some quick
attack Iran the beef i'll actually wow
it's just when a rupee to Quinn tank so
I'm not quite sure I'm a piece up so i
don't really need to meet him
immediately no but take the Queen yep
yeah 10 out of 10 but some guy is really
following closely here come on give me a
game okay oops okay
this is actually a one known theoretical
line which is just winning for white at
least an exchange
try to get the a porn rolling quickly c6
is also gone yeah yeah the a porn also
should promote would be actually nice of
him to to just resign but it doesn't
okay 22 points okay this is a good one
play play chess l is absurd Wow 22 mouth
lips in a row great and now I'm in this
crap here what is this kid it looks like
a French
yeah maybe this is still playable it's
not great but you're threatening on c7
okay I'll take the take this pawn I'm
really just opponent
I Bishop g6 ok still possible
yeah we only resigned ok they didn't
they only at nine seconds or something
ok no I don't take it wrong
so some trick here man maybe he's
overlooking this Bishop yep it's the
sauce long queen moose can be easy to
overlook or age seven
yeah this is the queen oh I'm actually
playing the second place to play and the
tournament funny come on yeah I'm
slightly behind on the club by down
manage come on oops it's my move yeah I
managed to stay made great somehow I
didn't really realize it was my move now
well for a joke yeah well people simply
don't resign he lose to queenstown okay
this is really strange what what what
the my players doing here I guess he
just wants to finish this game quickly
oops and you could just resign which
would would be helpful actually
let's try to to mate quickly here after
gifted away this half a point last game
is there some maiden one I don't see it
yeah but this is made next more fried
yeah okay I'm still ahead because why
was this gifted draw to the second place
player he didn't really catch up okay
this was some some opening misstep and
what I'm still okay here very okay
actually the asics nidus is not good
this is okay thanks it was very good
anyway with this helped of course going
for Bishop to e6
what did i do it down this was the worst
possible technical play here what is
this okay lost on time somehow I had
some some message on the screen very
irritating okay four minutes left most
likely two or three games at best let's
try to collect a couple of more k this
check should be good
yeah it would be nice if you would
actually resign but people just don't do
that
maybe I could have taken this all yet
let's try to build some wait here okay
one mate you cannot do much again this
except some desperado sex or letting the
clock run down is also one typical and
fair play always very much appreciated
yeah it just let the clock run down oh I
need to be cautious knows no stay and
made or something okay yeah very close I
think just win this and I should have it
in the bag maybe already have I'm not
quite sure but great opponent
disconnected yeah well okay the opponent
he has got minus 27 so he must have lost
I don't know all his games or something
and now he's playing one guy with 30
points so a little bit of frustration is
certainly understandable but you can
just if you want to stop to turn you can
just hit pause and you don't get paired
anymore so instead of spoiling other
people's Tony you should just quit this
and just hit pause but people yeah a lot
of people simply don't follow some basic
rules of fair play very annoying is this
time running down thing if let's say
he's got tier 15 seconds left and the
tournament would last ten seconds then I
wouldn't get the point which is some
yeah very awful if it decides the
tournament
okay four seconds and so on okay I'm
just one point ahead maybe I even get
caught due to this idiocy and now I get
a good good opponent actually yam this
wasn't a great start action and to be
honest got our own somewhat bad position
but maybe it's still playable
well yeah this was getting close again
at the end but I did it the other one
didn't get a winnin so I actually won
this thing with 31 points yesterday I
guys scored 40 let's check whicli the
final table yeah I'm just leading by one
point but yeah well I had two weeks to
Queens against the second place so this
was the only draw I conceded so okay
yeah well thanks for watching the video
I hope you enjoyed a couple of quick
bullet games I didn't play so great but
I hope it was entertaining as well um
yeah I think about I'll maybe take a
note note it down you can endure this
charity event down the 17th it's in
Goose I'm 02 02 s cafe so you can also
with it this cafe here also before the
tournament of course to get more
information about about the event yeah
thanks for watching and listening see
you soon with new videos cheers and bye